yeah well Han sometimes things are
better the second time around I think
I'd say he became a motherfucker
well guys it's that time of year again
the weather outside is frightful and
what am I thinking about die hard now
yes I have reviewed these four films in
the past but that was a long time ago
and I feel that I didn't really give
this first film the in-depth review that
it deserves because it's a silent
Guardian it's watchful Brittany my bad I
just I get lost sometimes thinking about
that man die hard is a revolutionary
action film and a lot of people don't
necessarily view it maybe the same way
that I do I grew up with it first of all
I would watch this film endlessly every
summer it was just die hard or die hard
and then in the winter you feel the same
thing you'd want to watch die hard it
was one of those weird movies where it's
like it takes place during Christmas but
you feel like you can just watch it
whenever because it's just such a unique
action film for its time nowadays it's
been copied and imitated in every way
Bruce Willis plays John McClane one of
the most likable protagonists in movie
history you just immediately from frame
one you love this guy because he's not
just your standard shoot him up kill
everyone and win and get the girl guy
he's a vulnerable hero and you get that
from scene one why because when the
movie opens you see him on this plane
and he's totally afraid of flying he's
this awesome hero badass but he does not
want to fly on planes as these opening
scenes progress you have a very limited
time to learn about this character that
was one of the challenges I'm sure the
filmmakers had in this movie because the
action starts fairly early on but you
got to immediately relate to this guy
and you do because of these opening
scenes you learn about him through
Argyle in the limo when he looks at the
computer and he realizes that his wife
has changed her name in the directory to
her maiden name and he's like huh the
scenes where he's trying to reconnect
with his wife you feel that this guy is
a person and you immediately get that in
such a short time
it's brilliant script writing and very
good directing and when you think of die
hard it's so easy to just think of this
a really fun movie but when you really
examine this film John McTiernan the
director did such a good job directing
this movie and we'll talk more about him
later but as you guys probably know Alan
Rickman and one of his best and most
signature roles comes in with his
terrorist buddies rounds up hostages and
talks to mr. Takagi they're after the
money in this fault and they're gonna do
anything to get it now guess what they
didn't expect there just so happens to
be a New York cop in the other
and he's gonna make things messy for
them this was just such a cool premise
for its time when it came out in 1988
this movies been done and done again in
so many different ways now but for its
time one guy against a group of
terrorists and a this tall building has
to save all these people everyone's
against him that wasn't as common as a
premise back then as I said John
McTiernan is a fantastic action director
a lot of people don't realize just how
many movies this guy's directed that are
great first off I really like die hard 3
die hard with a vengeance is actually my
favorite die hard sequel he also
directed The Hunt for Red October a
great film with Alec Baldwin and Sean
Connery and oh yeah predator predator
for goodness sakes if you guys don't
know predator is actually one of my
favorite movies along with die hard I
just predator this guy knows how to
direct suspenseful action scenes you
watch this movie and every shot feels
like it has life it actually is kind of
slow-paced at the beginning it's so
interesting because the characters but
the way he films it is it's just very
calm and laid-back you're like
something's going on here it's almost
like the opening scene to this movie are
that moment when you light a fuse and
the fires just sort of trailing along it
and then it explodes and that's when the
terrorism and everything happens in this
movie and John McClane has to be hero
and everything and then the rest of the
movies like the explosion but there's
opening scenes feel like a fuse being
lit you can just feel all these pieces
coming into place so well he just has
this way of directing each shot that
feels almost independent it just feels
so low-budget in the best way when he's
on top of the elevator and it's going up
the shaft and he's looking up and he
looks worried because he's actually on
an elevator going up a shaft and he's
probably worried is gonna get squashed
most of the action is in your face
extremely well shot lots of things in
wide angles you don't get the shaky cam
of nowadays as the movie goes along you
get to see this wonderful cat-and-mouse
game between McClane and Hans now here's
another challenge presented to these
filmmakers not only did they have to
open this movie and get you invested in
this character quickly but Hans and
McClane they don't really have scenes
together they have to create a
legitimate villain and hero presence in
this film and feel like they are
clashing without them actually being
together they just talk on a
walkie-talkie for almost the entire
movie
do you have any idea how hard that is
for a filmmaker to approach that or a
writer to approach that and say how are
we gonna make this actually be a good
rivalry when they're never actually in
scenes together I'm so impressed with
how it works and the reason it works so
well is because as these terrorists are
introduced you see them and they have
this very straightforward goal-oriented
plan of how they're going to accomplish
everything but clean as he calls himself
is the fly in the ointment he's the guy
who keeps screwing everything up for
them and it's so fun and entertaining to
watch that and you really just feel this
guy eating at each one of these members
you feel him just breaking away at
they're calm and that's one of the
reasons why it works so well
diehard truly is an action classic it's
a film that you can watch over and over
and over again for the rest of your life
and you're never gonna get bored with it
if you like these types of movies and I
do
it's almost flawless I really only have
a couple little nitpicks with the movie
that don't affect my overall grade with
it but since I am a film reviewer I feel
required to tell you I only have two
issues with this film one is a character
reporter who seems completely
unnecessary to the plot really he's just
very annoying to like everyone in this
movie and I feel like every time they
show him the movie just loses momentum
and since he didn't really have a huge
purpose in the movie I feel like he
could just been deleted apparently some
people enjoyed that character because he
gets brought back for die hard too and a
much more extensive role also this isn't
really a nitpick it's just sort of a
thought one of the things I noticed
watching this movie again last night
everyone in this movie except John
McClane is a douchebag
obviously the terrorists okay we go in
there back we got that but the reporter
the cop who doesn't believe anything
McClane says the cops on the phone who
also don't believe what McClane says the
sleazy Ellis dude who just wants to get
everything done his way Johnson &
Johnson up in the helicopter even the
good guys in this movie are like they're
douchebags like no one no one helps John
McClane in this movie except of course
Carl from Family Matters who loves his
Twinkies and it's gonna be said that
hostess is going out of business
and I just noticed I was like this movie
really stacks everyone against this
character and that is actually a
positive in the long run because you
just feel like this guy has no one just
someone give this guy a helping hand you
get that a little bit through Reginald
veljohnson this character yes I know
his name I used to watch Family Matters
and I saw it pop up on the screen every
day die hard is a pristinely directed
smartly written action film with a very
likeable hero in a very likable villain
it is one of the best action films ever
made I love die hard it of course gets
an A+ so thanks a lot for watching guys
I hope you are enjoying your day off
don't do anything stupid stay safe and
as always if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes